opposers this can't wait the
opposition's very own Coby Libby has
confronted a potential crisis actor
posing as the real Alex Jones in
Washington DC
sir are you the real Alex Jones and all
the people that look and act like actors
look at the Aurora shooting that was
totally sick and they may actually even
have some experience in you know acting
you're an actor pretending to be a
journalist pretending to be a comedian I
mean you said they're confuse your
audience like you're a new show I don't
think I don't think a person putting on
a big perform to show claiming to be a
journalist but you following oh now I
want to be clear we didn't call this
Alex Jones crisis actor a crisis actor
we merely looked at the crisis actor
like behavior of this crisis actor like
man speaking from what felt like a
script and said others might say Alex
Jones is a crisis actor besides that's
sad sorry man looks nothing like the
real AJ I'm supposed to believe that guy
gave advice to the President of the
United States no way
sad
the fight continues you you a deep state
operative is sent by George Soros to
take away my second Amendment rights and
for speedy soy burgers No well then
prove it
click and subscribe and join the
opposition now